new show on this trip is getting an
extension thanks to great reviews and
strong ticket sales Illuminati or
illuminate I should say has been
extended until June of next year I guess
I'm in conspiracy mode here here to shed
more light on that is Mateo Dobbins the
captain of the dance team Victor Ramos
also one of the performers welcome both
of you we love right now yeah we're live
this TV yeah this is it where's my
camera okay no no no oh my gosh this is
this is we're going Mateo right there
take over my camera what's up people
where you at hey right there you had it
welcome welcome to the show
[Laughter]
my hands okay I'll make you proud can we
continue now are we good
get with me
you guys I'm excited for you you guys
obviously have a lot of energy and a lot
of fun in the show uh and were you
excited when you heard it was extended
oh for sure for sure Vegas has been kind
to us man and distract that they've been
working with us the show's getting
bigger getting better so I feel like
next year it's going to be even crazier
I can tell you how crazy because you
gotta come check it out to see how we
Elevate is this always Mateo is he
always like on this level right here
absolutely yeah yeah it's a plan okay so
people who haven't seen the show
illuminate tell us what they can expect
oh just fun man it's a show based in the
dark as you see right there that's
that's us is that you that's too big
a lot of dancing a lot of different
styles and genres of music but most
importantly what we try to do different
is we don't want you just watch the show
we want you to have fun so it's almost
like we're bringing the party to you
well listen if you're if your energy is
any indication of what goes on people
are in good shape and it's getting such
good reviews in fact it was voted in
best of Vegas uh the best date night
show right
look is in the air right it's terrific
you know yeah but it's just it's for
families as well right yeah all ages
it's a club for all ages man come
through we even I'm gonna tell you what
we do you got to come see the show but
you come check it out there's some music
for all genres all different age groups
it's a blast okay Mateo we're gonna get
you to come out of your shell all right
next time we get you on here we've got a
lot of fun both of you congratulations
the show's doing great I'm happy for
both of you and I'm excited that the
show is going to continue thank you all
right a dark Tuesday nights right
otherwise yeah we're gonna check it out
eight o'clock and next year we start at
seven o'clock this pretty face is going
to be there you won't be able to see it
but we're gonna be there but you'll know
it's pretty all the same you can check
out illuminate performances at the strap
just go to illuminate.com or Illuminati
if you just want to like get real about
it and you get to check out the schedule
and purchase tickets